hello everyone welcome to our final
screencast in our unit on distributed
word representations our topic is going
to be deriving static representations
from contextual models that might sound
awfully specific but as you'll see i
think this could be really empowering
for you as you work on your original
system for the assignment and the
associated bake off
so let's dive in a question on your
minds might be how can i use bert or
related models like roberta or excel net
or electro in the context of deriving
good static representations of words you
probably have heard about these models
and heard that they lift all boats and
the question is how can you take
advantage of those of those benefits
but there's a tension here we've been
developing static representations but
these models like bert are
designed to deliver contextual
representations of words and i'll return
to what that means in a second but that
is the central tension between static
and contextual so the question is are
there good methods for deriving static
representations from the contextual ones
that these models offer
and the answer from bamasan yet all is
yes there are effective methods for
doing this and it's those methods that
will be the focus of this screencast i
really want to do two things though for
this lecture i would like to get hands
on a little bit with a high level
overview of models like bert we're going
to look later in the quarter in much
more detail at how these models work so
for now we're just going to treat them
as kind of black boxes just like you
might look up a glove representation of
a word and just get back that
representation and use it so too here we
can think of these models as devices for
feeding in sequences and getting back
lots and lots of representations that we
might use and later in the quarter we'll
come to a deeper understanding of
precisely where those representations
come from
and in addition of course i want to give
you an overview of these exciting
methods from bomasani at all in the
hopes that they are useful to you in
developing your original system
so let's start with the structure of
burt
bert processes sequences here i've got a
sequence the class token the day broke
sep class and separate designated tokens
the class token typically starts the
sequence and then set ends the sequence
and can be also used internally in
sequences to mark boundaries within the
sequence that you're processing
but the fundamental thing is that we
have this the short sentence the day
broke
vert processes those into an embedding
layer and then a lot of additional
layers you know here i've depicted 4 but
it could be 12 or even 24 layers
what we're seeing here the vec the
rectangles represent vectors they are
the outputs of each layer in the network
a lot of computation goes into computing
those output vector representations at
each layer we're going to set that
computation aside for now so that we can
just think of this as a grid of vector
representations
here's the crucial thing that makes vert
contextual for different sequences that
we process we will get very different
representations in fact
individual tokens
occurring in different sequences we'll
get very different representations i've
tried to signal that with the colors
here so like the t's two sequences both
contain the word the and the word broke
but in virtue of the fact that they have
different surrounding material and
different positions in the sequence
almost all of the representations will
be different um
the class and set tokens might have the
same embedding but through all of these
layers because of the way all these
tokens are going to interact with each
other when we derive the representations
everything will be different we do not
get a static representation out of these
models and i've specified that even in
the embedding layer if the positions of
the words vary one in the same token
will get different representations the
reason for that is that this embedding
layer is actually hiding two components
we do it at the very center of this
model have a fixed static embedding
where we can look up individual word
sequences
but for this thing that i've called the
embedding layer that static
representation is combined with a
separate positional encoding from a
separate embedding space and that
delivers what i've called the embedding
layer here and that means that even at
this first layer because for example the
occurs in different points in the
sequence it will get different
representations even in the embedding
space
and from there of course as we travel
through these layers we expect even more
things to change about the
representations
a second important preliminary is to
give some attention to how bert and
models like it tokenize sequences
and here i've given you a bit of code in
the hopes that you can get hands-on and
get a feel for how these tokenizers
behave i'm taking advantage of the
hugging face library i have loaded a
burp tokenizer and i load that from a
pre-trained model
in cell 3 you can see that i've called
the tokenized function on the sentence
this isn't too surprising and the result
is a pretty normal looking sequence of
tokens you see some punctuation has been
separated off but you also see a lot of
words when you get down to cell 4 though
for the sequence in codeme this is a bit
surprising the word encode in the input
has been broken apart into two sub-word
tokens
en and then code with these boundary
markers on it bert has broken that apart
into two subword sequences and if i feed
in a sequence that has a really
unfamiliar set of
tokens in it it will do a lot of
breaking a part of that sequence as you
can see in cell five for the input
snuffleupagus where a lot of these
pieces have come out this is the
essential piece for why bert is able to
have such a small vocabulary only about
30 000 words compare that with the 400
000 words that are in the glove space
the reason it can get away with that is
that it does a lot of breaking apart of
words into sub word tokens
and of course because the model is
contextual we have an expectation that
for example when it encounters code here
in the context of en at some conceptual
level the mother will recognize that his
process the word encode even though it
was two tokens underlyingly
let's flesh this out a bit by looking at
the full interface for dealing with
these models i'm again taking advantage
of hugging face i'm going to load a burp
model and a burp tokenizer it's
important that they use the same
pre-trained weights which hugging face
will download for you from the web and
so those are tied in and i set up the
tokenizer and the model if i call
tokenizer.encode on a sequence it would
give me back a list of indices and those
indices will be used as a lookup to
start the process of computing this
entire sequence in cell 6 i actually use
the model to derive that grid of
representations hugging faces giving us
an object that has a lot of attributes
if i call
output hidden states equals true when i
use the model here then i can call dot
hidden states and get that full grid of
representations that i showed you before
so this is a sequence with 13 layers
that's one embedding layer plus 12 of
the additional layers
and if i key into one of like the first
layer that will be the embedding you can
see that its shape is one by five by 768
this is a batch of one example it has
five tokens the three that we can see
here plus the class and set tokens and
each one of those tokens in the
embedding layer is represented by a
vector of dimension 768
and that remains consistent through all
the layers in the model so if i went to
the final output states i again just
index into dot hidden states here the
shape is the same and that will be
consistent for all the layers
those are the preliminaries and let's
think about how we could derive some
static representations the first
approach that bom asani and all consider
is what they call the decontextualized
approach and this is like the simplest
thing possible we are just going to
process individual words as though they
were sequences and see if burke can make
any sense of them so we would start by
feeding in a word like kitten and we
would allow the model to break it apart
into its sub-word pieces and then we
simply process that with the model we
get a full grid of representations
now because we potentially have sub-word
tokens here we need some cooling
function so what we could do is just
pool using something like mean to get a
fixed static representation of dimension
for this individual word
and of course we don't have to use the
final layer we could use lower down
layers and we don't have to use mean as
the pouring function you could consider
something like max or min or even last
which would just disregard all of the
vector representations except for the
one corresponding to the final sub word
token
this is really simple uh it's
potentially unnatural though bird is a
contextual model it was trained on full
sequences and especially if we leave off
the class and sep tokens we might be
feeding in sequences that bert has
really never seen before and so it might
be unknown how it's going to behave with
these unusual inputs nonetheless though
we could repeat this process for all the
words in our vocabulary and derive a
static embedding space and maybe it has
some promise
however to address this potential
unnaturalness and potentially take more
advantage of the the virtues that burt
and related models have bomasani at all
consider also the aggregated approach so
in this approach you process lots of
corpus examples that contain your target
word here i've got a sort of glimpse of
a corpus our target word is kitten of
course we allow it to be broken apart
into sub-word tokens the full sequences
in these examples would also be broken
apart into sub-word tokens
but the important thing is that our
target word might have sub word tokens
we pool those as we did before for the
contextualized approach and we're also
going to pool across all of the
different context examples that we
processed
and the result of that should be a bunch
of natural inputs to the model but in
the end we derive a static
representation that is some kind of
average across all of the examples that
we processed
it seems very natural it's taking
advantage of what what bird is best at i
will warn you though that this is very
computationally demanding we're going to
want to process lots of examples and
burt requires lots of resources because
it develops really large representations
as we've seen
but it might be worth it
now bumasonia would offer lots of
results that help us understand these
approaches and how they perform uh let
me give you a glimpse of them as a kind
of summary so what we've got here is
results for the simverb 3500 data set a
word similarity data set that's very
similar to the ones that you'll be
working with on the homework and bake
off
our metric is spearmint correlation and
higher is better that's along the y-axis
and along the x-axis i have the layer in
the model that we're keying into
and then of course what we should watch
is that we have two pooling functions f
and g f is subword pooling and g is
context pooling for models that have it
and it's decomped for the
decontextualized approach
now we have a very clear result across
these results and i think across all the
results in the paper lower layers are
better
lower layers are giving us good high
fidelity representations of individual
words as we travel higher in the model
we seem to lose a lot of that word level
discrimination
in addition your best choice is to do
mean pooling for the context
and subwood pooling seems to matter less
right all of these lines here are all
for the context pooling model with mean
as your context pooling function
the very best choice though i think
consistently is mean for both of these
pooling functions here
um you can see that in this result and i
think that's consistent across all the
results in the paper but
the
overall takeaway here is that as
expected the aggregated approach is
better than the decontextualized
approach
however if you don't have the
computational budget for that then mean
pooling in the decontextualized approach
looks really competitive that's not so
evident in this plot but if you look
across all the results in the paper i
think that's a pretty clear finding so
that would be a good choice and one
thing is clear that simple approach is
better than some kinds of context
pooling where you choose the wrong
context pooling function like min or max
despite all of the effort that went into
this set of results and also these
they're all kind of down here entangled
with the decontextualized approach
but
mean as the pooling function there is
really an outstanding choice as you can
see from these results